where are you at now like you know p
people want to people enjoy seeing you
fight it's a very
uh there are certain people that draw
you draw hands down if you got a fight
people are buying that pay-per-view
because you're just that kind of an
electric electrifying fighter that
people want to see have you made up your
mind on what your next moves are are you
because there's speculation of ufc but
you're talking about tyson fury there's
a lot of different things that are
coming up what are some of your plans
that you're thinking about when they can
talk about i mean uh i don't have it i
haven't made a plan yet um
and also
we have a contrast situation to figure
out but
i want to point out the fact that
whether is a tizen fury or whatever uh
he can still happen under the ufc you
know uh when i said uh i want to box or
i want uh to fight tyson fury that
doesn't exclude exclude
the usa you know
he can't be under the usa as long as we
have a
good contract a respectful term um that
is
uh
that has been agreed
by both party i think everything is
possible
question let's just say you we you
continue with a contract let's just say
you renegotiate a contract with ufc and
the contract says it's all in but you
can't fight boxing the contract can says
if i renegotiate the contract the
contract would technically say it's what
i want okay that's what mean negotiation
contract make sense i mean
it's both party negotiating sure so uh i
have what i want they have what they
want and then
negotiating i mean like trying to
compromise and find a middle ground
would one of the things be important to
you to be able to fight in ufc and do
boxing outside of ufc would that be
something that's important to you
uh that's a possibility that's something
that's the option yeah if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you